El 2022 comenzó casi como un viaje atrás
en el tiempo. El protagonismo internacional
volvió a situarse sobre el antiguo territorio
de la extinta Unión Soviética.
Un despliegue masivo de tropas rusas en la
frontera con Ucrania dio la bienvenida al
año 2022, y el día 6 de enero se puso en
marcha en Kazajistán la primera misión militar
de la conocida como “Organización del Tratado
de Seguridad Colectiva”, una especie de
OTAN encabezada por Rusia. Algo así como
la heredera del Pacto del Pacto de Varsovia.
Hablamos en este caso de un despliegue de
unos 2.500 soldados bajo el mando de este
hombre,
el Coronel General ruso Andrei Serdyukov,
el mismo tipo que dirigió las operaciones
militares para apoderarse de Crimea en 2014,
y que luego comandó las fuerzas rusas en
Siria.
(Entre las tropas enviadas a Kazajistán se
encontraban unidades de la 45a brigada de
las fuerzas especiales rusas. Una unidad famosa
por sus operaciones en las guerras de Chechenia,
por su participación en la anexión de Crimea
y por su intervención en Siria.
Unas tropas, que en esta ocasión fueron enviadas
a Kazajistán para reprimir las violentas
protestas que con la llegada del nuevo año
se desataron en buena parte del país contra
el gobierno del presidente Kassym-Jomart Tokayev.)
Kazajistán queridos amigos es uno de los
países más grandes del mundo y un importante
actor en la industria energética mundial.
Para que os hagáis una idea, entre otros
muchos recursos, este país cuenta con las
décimo-segundas mayores reservas de petróleo
y produce más del 40% de todo el uranio que
se extrae a nivel mundial.
Ahora bien, ¿Qué ocurrió exactamente en
Kazajistán? ¿Por qué tuvieron que intervenir
las tropas rusas? ¿Qué explica el creciente
intervencionismo de la Rusia de Vladímir
Putin? ¿Qué consecuencias puede tener?
Pues bien, veámoslo.
[Por cierto, un momento antes de continuar.
La pandemia del coronavirus ha puesto sobre
la mesa un nuevo tipo de política económica.
Hoy conceptos como austeridad o equilibrio
presupuestario han quedado totalmente excluidos
del discurso político. Y la pregunta es,
¿Qué está detrás de este nuevo “paradigma
económico”?.
Para responder a esta pregunta no te pierdas
el último vídeo de Si lo Hubiera Sabido,
el canal de actualidad financiera de Mutuactivos.
Os dejamos el link en la descripción.]
Dicho esto continuemos.
(UNA PLUTOCRACIA EN LLAMAS)
El día 1 de enero el gobierno kazajo eliminó
el control de precios sobre el GLP, un combustible
mezcla de butano y propano que en algunas
regiones de Kazajistán es muy utilizado.
Por ejemplo, es el combustible que usa la
inmensa mayor parte de los automóviles de
este país.
Y, claro, tras eliminarse el control de precios,
el coste del GLP para los kazajos se incrementó
de la noche a la mañana en un 140%. Fue algo
así como la gota que colmó el vaso.
Porque, amigos, Kazajistán es un país que
durante las últimas 3 décadas ha hecho inmensas
cantidades de dinero gracias a todos sus recursos
naturales.
Sin embargo, pese a ello el estándar de vida
general es bastante reducido. El salario medio
ronda los 570 dólares al mes y la inmensa
mayor parte de los trabajadores ganan mucho
menos.
Amigos, durante años el gobierno de Kazajistán
ha convertido al país en una de las mayores
plutocracias del mundo. ¿Pero de qué estamos
hablando exactamente? ¿Queréis una prueba?
Pues… Fijaos, según KPMG tan solo 162 personas
controlan más del 55% de toda la riqueza
del país.
Y no, no hablamos de emprendedores o empresarios
de éxito. La mayoría son parientes, amigos
o aliados del antiguo líder Nursultan Nazarbayev,
una condición que les abrió de par en par
las riquezas del país.
Así es Kazajistán.
(El caso es que la situación estalló el
día 2 enero cuando las protestas se desataron
en Zhanaozen, un pequeña ciudad de la era
soviética próxima al Mar Caspio. Y desde
allí pronto se extendieron por gran parte
del país al tiempo que del precio del GLP
se pasó a a una crítica general contra el
gobierno.
Inicialmente las protestas fueron pacíficas
pero de repente y sobre todo en Almaty, la
principal ciudad del país, las cosas se salieron
de madre. A las protestas se unieron grupos
mucho más violentos que no dudaron en enfrentarse
a las fuerzas de seguridad:
En Almaty, por ejemplo, prendieron fuego a
coches de policía, al ayuntamiento, asaltaron
comisarías, almacenes, intentaron tomar el
aeropuerto e incluso se hicieron con un montón
de armas.)
Hablamos de toda una guerra campal, con un
resultado devastador: por un lado, más de
una docena de policías y miembros de las
fuerzas de seguridad perdieron la vida, por
otro las bajas entre los manifestantes se
cuentan por decenas. Seguramente, incluso,
por centenas.
(9 de enero de 2022: Las autoridades de Kazajstán
dicen que hay 164 muertos en las protestas
y que el país ya está "estabilizado''. WP)
Unas cifras oficiales que todo apunta a que
se quedan muy lejos de la realidad.
Y es que amigos, la respuesta del gobierno
fue implacable: solicitó la intervención
de las tropas extranjeras, autorizó a las
fuerzas de seguridad para que pudieran disparar
a matar sin previo aviso, decretó el estado
de alarma, el toque de queda y se ordenó
buscar a los manifestantes casa por casa.
(“El departamento de policia, de cinco pisos,
era una especie de transportador de tortura.
Los gritos se podían escuchar desde todas
las ventanas. Las torturas fueron horribles”.
Aset Abishev, participante en las protestas
contra el gobierno en Almaty.)
¿Pero cómo se llegó a este punto?¿Qué
buscaban en realidad las protestas?
hay muchas incógnitas y nadie tiene del todo
claro qué demonios pasó. Hay hipótesis
para todos los gustos:
Qué si la cosa se desmadró porque algunos
oligarcas locales quisieron aprovecharse de
las protestas para ganar influencia;
Qué si en realidad fueron aliados de Nazarbayev
quienes estuvieron detrás de todo,
Qué si fue cosa del Kremlin, qué si fuerzas
extranjeras
Que si todo fue cosa, simplemente, de una
juventud harta de malvivir en un país repleto
de riquezas.
O quizás una combinación de varias de estas
hipótesis.
En cualquier caso, lo que sí sabemos a ciencia
cierta es que el gobierno del Presidente Tokayev,
apoyado por Rusia, desencadenó una enorme
represión y una gigantesca operación de
castigo durante los días siguientes. Se calcula
que las autoridades han detenido a más de
10.000 personas.
Eso y que toda esta explosiva situación ha
dejado claros ganadores y perdedores. ¿Alguna
idea?
Pues… fijaos, el primer ganador claro ha
sido el propio presidente Tokayev.
Y es que, veréis, hasta ahora este presidente,
que llegó al poder en 2019 tras la renuncia
del histórico dictador Nursultan Nazarbayev,
había tenido en cierta forma que compartir
el poder con él. Porque aunque Nazarbayev
renunció formalmente, se aseguró de ser
nombrado “líder de la nación” y jefe
del Consejo de Seguridad Nacional.
(“Tokayev pudo poner fin a este doble poder
esquizofrénico en el país [..] Nunca se
convirtió en un presidente plenamente empoderado...
porque tenía las manos atadas”. Arkady
Dubnov, experto de Asia Central en el Carnegie
Moscow Center.)
Sin embargo, los disturbios lo han cambiado
todo. Tokayev ha nombrado un nuevo gobierno,
ha cesado al mismísimo Nazarbayev como Jefe
del Consejo de Seguridad Nacional y ha depurado
a muchos aliados y parientes del antiguo líder.
Este es, por ejemplo, el caso de Kair Massimov,
responsable de la agencia de inteligencia
de Kazajistán y una de las manos derechas
de Nazarbayev que ha sido cesado, detenido
y acusado de traición.
Otro ejemplo es el de Samar Abish, sobrino
del antiguo líder que fue despedido como
subdirector del principal servicio de seguridad
del país.
Y no solo eso, el propio presidente también
ha culpado en el parlamento al antiguo líder
de crear un estado oligárquico que ha enriquecido
a unos pocos a costa de la mayoría.
[Cómo si él estuviera libre de pecado]
("Los disturbios se han convertido en una
oportunidad real de demostrarle a los kazajos
que en casa solo puede haber un xdueño. Tokayev
es a día de hoy la principal figura política
del país y la que toma las decisiones importantes".
Eduard Poletáev, politólogo kazajo)
De hecho esto es lo que podría explicar la
propia intervención de las fuerzas rusas.
Dejar claro a todos los órganos de poder
de Kazajistán que Tokayev es quien manda
y que tiene el aval y el respaldo del mismísimo
Vladimir Putin. Es decir, que el despliegue
ruso en realidad no se llevó a cabo para
frenar las protestas sino sobre todo para
apuntalar al actual presidente.
("Para Tokayev era importante mostrar a la
gente, a las élites de Kazajstán, que es
la persona por la que Putin está apostando”.
Alexander Libman, q jefe del departamento
de política de la Universidad Libre de Berlín)
Lo que nos lleva directamente al segundo gran
ganador de esta tormenta: Vladimir Putin.
Y es que veréis, hasta ahora Kazajistán
trató siempre de mantener un cierto equilibrio
en sus relaciones con Rusia, China y Estados
Unidos.
De hecho, Nazarbayev abrió de par en par
el país a las grandes petroleras norteamericanas
y también europeas. Hoy empresas como Chevron
o Exxon Mobil tienen miles y miles de millones
de dólares invertidos en el país.
(En términos políticos las relaciones de
Nazarbayev con Estados Unidos fueron siempre
por lo general bastante buenas. Pero ahora
esa equidistancia se ha roto.
Tokayev se ha echado en brazos de Moscú y
de Vladimir Putin. Y eso, eso es algo que
puede marcar un antes y un después.
Kazajistán es la segunda mayor economía
de las ex repúblicas soviéticas tras la
propia Rusia. Y ahora la influencia del Kremlin
parece por primera vez casi total.)
Empieza fuerte el 2022 para el líder ruso.
Por su parte si estos son los grandes vencedores
está claro que también hay grandes perdedores,
además, claro está, de los propios manifestantes.
Todo apunta a que uno es el antiguo líder
Nursultan Nazarbayev y gran parte de su entorno.
El otro es Occidente, particularmente los
Estados Unidos que de la noche a la mañana
puede haber perdido la mayor parte de su influencia
en el país en favor de Moscú.
Un Moscú que últimamente parece no para
de apuntarse más y más tantos.
Atentos.
(EL COSTE DEL IMPERIO)
Rusia ha encontrado un nicho de mercado en
el que su política exterior resulta imbatible:
Ganar influencia a cambio de apoyar y proteger
a líderes autocráticos: Es algo que ha hecho
en Siria, en Bielorrusia, en Venezuela y ahora
en Kazajistán entre otros lugares.
(Vladimir Putin está logrando lo que hace
unos años parecía casi imposible: recuperar
buena parte de la influencia que antaño tenía
Moscú. Empezando por los antiguos estados
soviéticos.
Y no se trata solo de apoyar a gobiernos autocráticos.
El despliegue de más de 100 mil hombres en
la frontera con Ucrania deja muy claras las
intenciones del Kremlin: con Moscú no se
juega.)
Y, ojo, no penséis que se trata solo del
creciente activismo político-militar, sino
sobre todo de una estrategia que lleva años
ejecutándose. Durante las últimas dos décadas
Vlaidimir Putin ha modernizado el ejército,
desarrollado nuevas divisiones de fuerzas
especiales, ciberguerra, mercenarios y operativos
de inteligencia.
Todo para poder recuperar la vieja influencia
de Moscú. Todo para que la madre Rusia pueda
volver a ser grande.
Ahora bien, un momento, porque toda esta aventura
no resulta gratuita: tiene un precio muy alto.
Hablamos de un coste económico y también
estratégico.
Me explico. Por un lado sostener este imperio
es algo que resulta muy costoso: Todas estas
aventuras requieren de un nivel de gasto cada
vez mayor, lo que conlleva detraer recursos
de la sociedad civil para destinarlos a expandir
la influencia del estado.
Es algo que los rusos conocen muy bien de
su experiencia soviética.
La URSS destinó tantos recursos a mantener
su capacidad militar que estos terminaron
dejando exhaustos a todo el país… Y aún
así perdieron la Guerra Fría..
Por ejemplo, según datos del Pentágono,
entre 1974 y 1982, la Unión Soviética produjo
5,9 veces más misiles balísticos, 2,7 veces
más tanques, 7,6 veces más vehículos blindados,
el doble de aviones o 2,3 veces más submarinos.
Produjo más de todo.
Pero no les valió de nada, la influencia
de Moscú fue efímera y terminó cayendo
a medida que la economía soviética colapsó.
Ni siquiera tuvieron nunca la sensación de
estar por delante de los norteamericanos que
lideraban la carrera tecnológica y tenían
una capacidad de inversión en equipos de
vanguardia incomparablemente mayor.
(El excesivo peso que en Rusia tiene el ejército
y la política exterior está haciendo que
al mismo tiempo que Moscú recupera su influencia,
la economía local y el nivel de vida de los
rusos no logre mejorar.
El PIB ruso medido en dólares alcanzó su
nivel máximo en el año 2013, su dependencia
de los recursos naturales no se ha reducido
y las infraestructuras, los hospitales y las
escuelas del país se encuentran en un estado
calamitoso.
Esto es lo que explica que según las encuestas
realizadas, por ejemplo, por el Centro Lavada
más del 50% de los jóvenes rusos quieran
emigrar a otro país.)
Es decir, que Rusia ha hecho exactamente lo
contrario a lo que ha hecho China, cuya prioridad
durante las últimas décadas fue claramente
la economía.
Pero esto no es todo.
La economía rusa también se está viendo
perjudicada por las sanciones internacionales,
y las nuevas incursiones rusas podrían terminar
con nuevas sanciones que la castiguen aún
más.
Y la cuestión es, ¿Qué es más importante?
¿La influencia del estado en el mundo o el
nivel de vida de los propios ciudadanos rusos?
Nosotros lo tenemos claro, y ojo, porque son
los propios rusos quienes tampoco parecen
tener dudas.
(Según el Centro Lavada en 2021 solo el 32%
de los rusos querían ver a Rusia como una
potencia respetada y temida por otros países.
El 32%. Es decir, a la inmensa mayoría lo
que les preocupa es poder vivir mejor. )
Además, las últimas acciones rusas podrían
terminar con un final inesperado: el regreso
a una carrera armamentística que Rusia no
está en disposición de ganar.
Es decir, de tensarse la situación la OTAN
y sus miembros, particularmente los países
de Europa del Este podrían determinar blindar
la frontera con niveles de inversión militar
récords.
En su día esa carrera contribuyó decisivamente
al hundimiento de la Unión Soviética y puede
que el escenario hoy no sea muy diferente.
Así que sí, puede parecernos que hoy por
hoy Putin y Rusia están ganando una partida
y desde luego tienen importantes bazas: por
ejemplo la dependencia energética que la
Unión Europea sigue teniendo del oso ruso.
La UE obtiene el 41% de su consumo de gas
natural y el 27% de su petróleo de Rusia.
Pero a pesar de todo amigos, la historia puede
volver a repetirse. En cualquier caso, si
algo deja claro la última incursión en Kazajistán
es que estamos ante la Rusia más fuerte de
las últimas 3 décadas.
Pero llegados hasta aquí turno para ti:
¿Crees que la influencia del estado tiene
que situarse por encima del nivel de vida
de los ciudadanos? ¿Piensas que Rusia podrá
mantener su influencia internacional a pesar
de una economía renqueante que cada vez está
más lejos de las otras grandes potencias?
¿Cómo crees que los países occidentales
deben lidiar con Putin?
Dejanos por aquí abajo tus respuestas. Y
ahora si este vídeo te ha resultado interesante
no olvides darle a like y suscribirte a VisualPolitik.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.